hello everyone and welcome back to the
1911 a tournament of San Sebastiano we
are back with our kappa blanka saga and
here kappa blanka
faces a most dangerous opponent it is
polish grandmaster Kiba Rubinstein and
we could say that he is a was definitely
the strongest opponent here for
capablanca and just just to give you an
idea of how strong Rubinstein really was
in those days I have prepared the final
standings of the 1909 sankt-petersburg
tournament that also Emmanuel Lasker
visited it was a last curse first big
tournament after five years and here you
can see a Kiba Rubenstein shirt tied
first with 14 and a half out of 18 with
Emmanuel Lasker three and a half points
ahead of third rudolf gilman Capablanca
x' opponent from our previous game that
we've shown all the readerís then
awesome bernstein with 10 and half
richard TaqMan which 10 and so on and so
on
you can see Carl selector in the middle
middle of the board with 9 out of 18 and
it was because of this tournament I
don't know how many of you actually
checked the the article about car
selector and Emmanuel Alaska match I
recommended in the previous video but
Alaska actually tried to organize the
match and he took it upon himself to get
sponsorship for money for the prize
which is something of most often a
challenger would have to do not to the
champion but as the last guy really
thought it could be a very lucrative
match he like I said he decided to take
it upon himself but due to this I mean
ok in the end they did play the match
but it wasn't the match Lasker hoped for
Alaska hoped for a 30 game match where
they would both get a lot more money in
the end it was a 10 game match which we
already discussed but the problem is
after this 1909 San Pedro sport
tournament you can see that conflict
finished well somewhere in the middle of
the board with 9 out of 18 and it was
actually a keyboard machine who people
were hoping a would challenge Alaska for
the crown and okay later in
19:14 before the outbreak of World War
one there were negotiations between a
keyboard Winston and Manuel asked her
but the match never happened do you know
because of the war and everything and
later well Akiba wasn't playing at that
top level that he was playing now
but regardless really really a strong
player and he was he was really known
like the the master of the opening the
master of the middle game and like
capablanca a virtuoso in the endgame so
without further ado it's really an
incredible game capablanca even featured
it in his game
chest fundament in his book chest
fundamentals so even capablanca regards
it as a very impressive game so let's
just check it out Rubinstein has the
white pieces and he opens with d4 we
have d5 Knight to f3
we have c5 like in the previous game
where cuppa Blanca had the white pieces
against the Rudolph's Pillman and if you
remember I said that Capablanca here
played c3 which was not modern approach
to this opening that in motor then see a
c4 would be played and here rubenstein
does go for c4 allows capablanca the
transposing to the Tatars defense and
couple Blanca does we have e 6c Kaptur
Sun d5e Kaptur Sun d5 and Knight to c3
we are now into the two knights
variation of the tower defense and
Knight to c6 and here a Rubinstein goes
for g3 it was a well known move it was
first introduced by Carlos left two
years ago but Rubinstein really
perfected this variation and although
capablanca didn't really know this
variation he knew that Rubinstein was
the master of this variation and
capablanca knew that Knight to f6 was
the most common idea here but so many
games were known were white one against
such a line and then Capablanca just
went to Bishop to e6 to avoid any any
opening theory known by a keyboard opens
time and okay
I brush up to g2 we have Bishop to e7
and Rubinstein castles and here
Capablanca should have gone Knight to f6
which is what couple monka himself
mentions in his book you should really
hurry up with your development
get your king to safety but here couple
man who played rook to c8 and everyone
was well of course in post-mortem
analysis unimpressed by this move
compare Lanka keeps the king in the
centre for far too long and he ignores
his development well he doesn't think
nor his depend on the Queen side but the
Queen set development is a bit too slow
when you're King be still in the center
of the board but ok this is what
Capablanca was used to play you know
against other players he would just play
going to an endgame and then win the
game but Akiba Rubinstein is a much more
deadly opponent than than everyone else
so here comes D captures on c5 and this
move would come to haunt Capablanca well
for a long time but you'll see why we
have Bishop characters in c5 removing
the bishops control of the g5 Square and
now comes the Knight to g5 okay Arobin
wants to grab the bishop on e6 with
Knight to f6 Capablanca is preparing to
Castle Knight captures F captures and
now a Roman shine uses this idea that
the pawn on e6 is a weak bond it's also
an undefended pawn and the idea that
kappa blanka played looked to c8 to form
his next move which is Bishop to h3
still keeping Kappa Blancas king in the
center of the board not allowing him to
castle and forces couple Blanca to deal
with this weakness it would be best if
you could deal with the weakness by
simple pushing e5 but you can't since
the rook is on c8 so Queen to e7
defending the pawn and now later
everyone agreed that most likely since
the King was thrown in the century for
breaking a busting open the position
would have been the best choice here for
example D captures and only now Bishop
to g5 so Knight captures on e4 would
come with an attack on the pinned piece
for example castles Knight captures here
and white would be better here but
Rubinstein goes for a different line he
goes Bishop to g5 immediately
keeping the option open of playing e4
and here kappa blanka castles and
Capablanca mentions that now even though
he waited so long to castle now it's not
now because he waited so long to castle
now he castles prematurely he says rook
to d8 was a necessity here you cannot
leave it here
the bishop simply locks down blacks
entire position but okay capablanca
castled here and here we have a very
impressive combination by Maya Kiba
Rubinstein that Capablanca mentions in
his book that it's more most likely one
of the reasons that capablanca included
in his book here we have Bishop captures
on f6 and as Capablanca mentions in his
book he played Queen captures on f6 but
he saw that Ruben Schneider had the
possibility of a very nice combination
but he thought it it will not work he
thought he can defend it capablanca says
that okay after G captures on f6 III
have a semi-open G file I could perhaps
use it to attack but a white position
will be better but the capablanca says
that he saw a Rubenstein's idea and he
decided to allow it as he thought he
could defend couple Duncan played Queen
captures on f6 and now comes Knight
captures on d5 and this is why couple
Lanka thought that you could defend this
of course you cannot capture the night
if you capture you get Queen captures so
with Czech King has the move Bishop
captures an c8 rook captures and now the
whole point of this combination the
Bishop on c5 is unguarded
so Queen captures on c5 and you're
you're simply winning you're up the
exchange in a much better position
you're up to pawns also completely
winning for white another thing after
Knight captures on d5 Capablanca could
have gone for Bishop captures on f2
after all DF 2 square is attacked three
times by black but after King to h1 you
could go Queen to h6 get your queen out
of harm's way
attack the bishop on h3 and after king
here black has to move the bishop let's
say Bishop e3 Knight captures you could
go Queen captures on e3 but after Queen
to d3 we would reach this end game where
it would be a knight against the bishop
the Queen trade could happen but
Capablanca decided not to go for this
either so you cannot capture here but
you can capture an f2 if you want but
Capablanca found a different way to
refute this Knight captures on d5 idea
or so he thought
he played Queen to h6 simply get
his queen out of harm's way now you're
attacking the undefended bishop on h3
and also it's not a problem the knight
doesn't really have a good jump you're
in no danger of Knight moving and queen
ever coming to d5 you know checking your
King and grabbing the the Bishop on c5
and here kappa blanka said that he
thought okay the bishop is under attack
white has to go here and then Capablanca
saw this line 95 now the night is still
under attack you have to move it Knight
f4 and now Knight to g4 threatening
checkmate
after h3 Knight captures on f2 rook
captures Bishop captures and after King
captures g5 simply attacking the pinned
piece would win kappa blanka the game
but the move Rubinstein played is the
one cup of Blanca missed in this entire
madness here Rubinstein simply played
King to g2 he defended the bishop and
now the threat remains what do you play
here here you still cannot move you
still cannot capture this tension still
works in white favor so couple Blanca
played rook seat da and it seems
everything is alright now it's still not
clear how Rubinstein thought that this
could work
you can you still can't move the knight
you can't go Knight f6 or 97 deliver any
checks in hopes of you know saving your
night because the bishop in night cover
is 7 and f6 is fully guarded and you
can't move the knight the rook is no
longer in danger and c8 there is this
tension of rook captures Queen of the
Night Moves so it's very unclear what
Rubinstein saw when he played Knight
captures on d1 but he did see something
so feel free to pause the video here and
try to find the idea rubenstein hal
rubenstein had when he played rook and
Knight captures on d5 I'll give you a
couple of second you know as usual for
those who were able to do it
congratulations it's really an
outstanding idea and for those of you
who just wanna enjoy so the move
Rubinstein played was Queen to c1 and
now it all becomes clear okay you're
offering the Queen trade but that's not
the point
you are you are offering your night here
in exchange for grabbing the undefended
Bishop on c5 so here's the problem if
you trade
Queens first and then rook captures on
c1 or the other rope captures first
white will capture on e6 with chip and
only after King moves and now you will
recapture and the bishop now controls
the knight on d5 and also your Bishop
here is under attack
so capablanca decided to go for a
different line he played a character son
d5 and now comes Queen captures on c5 so
simply trading a piece Queen to see fire
very powerful move this Queen to c1
and now capablanca is simply down upon
and what's his what's his compensation
it's hard to say he plays Queen to d2
attacking both the e2 pawn ended the b2
pawn we have Queen to b5 defending both
points and also preparing to capture on
b7 and here comes Knight to d4
capablanca attacks the Rubenstein's
Queen on b5 but also pressures de to
pawn and indeed if you go for something
like Queen captures here then you get
Queen captures here and now it's
actually black that's better
even though down down material you will
have compensation and the very nice
attack with black so after this night
the d4 move now Rubenstein plays like
Capablanca and he forces a trade of
Queens while being up upon he plays
Queen to d3 now you cannot capture on e2
because your knight would be hanging and
you cannot capture with the night well
because your queen is handing so
Capablanca the trades Queens we have eke
actress on d3 and now rook F to e8 and
here Blanca says that rook after he won
would perhaps have been the better way
to confront black's rook on e8 but
Rubinstein goes for Bishop to g4
controlling e to this way not allowing
this rook to go down to the second rank
we have looked at these six by kappa
blanka now Capablanca will use this way
to try and create some threats against
the whites white pawns on the Queen side
we have rook F to e1 now comes
rope captures rook captures and rook to
b6 so Rubinstein still up upon but
Capablanca getting some some counter
play we have rook to e5 a very nice idea
by Rubenstein now if Capablanca grabs
the pawn which he does then Rubenstein
grabs the D pawn are also threatening
the
night so kappa blanka is not in time to
grab the other pone as well nights the
c6 and now comes Bishop to e6 check you
could also try something like rook to d7
the a to point is guarded indirectly
because of this tactic Bishop to e6
check which would pick up the rook but
it's not necessary if I mean if black
doesn't capture it then roof to d7 is
could be a waste of time
so first the Bishop to e6 check forcing
the King to move King f8 and now comes
Luke to f5 check we have looked a king
t8 and now Bishop to f7 check King to d7
and now comes Bishop to c4 and again
capablanca now says that rook to f7 is
definitely the threat after King moves
Rubenstein will start grabbing off the
Kings iPhones and he says that King to
d6 or rook to e2 with the idea of
blocking White's check on f7 by going
rook to D the rock 37 was the way to go
for him but Capablanca here played a6
and it's something that will come off as
a theme during this game but we're gonna
talk about this a bit later some more
rope to f7 check couple Baca decides to
give up the g7 pawn we have king to d6
and now rook captures on g7 and here
comes b5 Capablanca sacrifices upon to
start his pawn storm on the Queen side
we have Bishop the g8 and now comes a
five rook after Sun h7 grabbing another
pawn and now a four we have h4 by white
arrow mission also wants to start
pushing his past pawns and now comes b4
we have rook to h6 check King to c5 and
now rook to h5 check we have a king to
b6 and here Bishop to d5 simply
attacking the knight also the the threat
of rope to e6 is pretty big threatening
to win the night here but it's also not
the greatest of moves here capablanca
says in his book that Bishop to c4 is an
essential move because after Bishop to
d5 there is a move that allows the black
to create some serious complications but
Capablanca didn't play it he mentions in
his book that rook captures on a2 is
simply wonderful for black
now you would have to you would have to
either repeat Bishop to c4 and threaten
rugby 5 check or you would have to go
something like rook to h6 but then rook
to c2 defends the night and you can
start pushing your past a pawn and you
cannot capture the rook because of b3
you can move the bishop but then a3 and
any move you play doesn't really matter
white will simply push this and your
your queening here you can either
sacrifice it and then the other pawn
Queens or you can move the bishop and
then you simply get a queen and win the
game so a definitely an interesting
moment after this Bishop to d5
capablanca doesn't mention if he saw
this during the game or if he considered
it or why he didn't go for it so maybe
he found it later after the game it's
hard to say but that's why it's
interesting that couple Blanca mentions
that Bishop to c4 would have been better
here because now rook captures doesn't
work here because of rugby 5 check and
now after King moves simply Bishop
captures and now the same idea of b3
doesn't work because better captures
pawn captures and now rook is ready to
capture the pawn you're up the exchange
and up for pawns winning of course
so after this King to b6 Bishop to d5
was played and knock up a manga plays b3
and okay we have a capture son b3 and
now a3 Capablanca says that most likely
again Capablanca doesn't mention why he
didn't go for that rook captures on a
two line but perhaps he thought that he
had Rubinstein here but Rubinstein finds
the absolute best idea
he plays Bishop captures and c6 and
here's the problem
a two doesn't win for black here maybe
couple monk I thought it does it's hard
to say but a two doesn't work because of
a very specific reason
now again feel free to pause the video
here and try to find how does white win
here I'll give you a couple of seconds
as usual for those of you who were able
to do it congratulations you know you
are you are rivaling Rubenstein's
endgame skill which is you know up there
with half a Blancas but rook to b5 check
is the idea and now it doesn't matter if
you
after the bishop then Luke a5 and you no
longer will be able to promote your a
pond and the white is up so much
material that it would be winning and on
the other hand if you don't do it if you
go something like King a six not allow
Luke a five then you had to find it this
move rook b8 again you can go rotate one
because of Luke a8 and now there's
really nothing more to do here you would
have to cap from b3 and after rook
checks here King moves rook captures
King captures on c6 and now simple roof
to D to the Feniger pawn you're up four
points completely winning so this is
what Rubenstein's thought when he played
Bishop captures in c6 capablanca cannot
push a to soak up a Blanca played route
capture son b3 we have Bishop to d5
attacking couple Blancos rook here a
couple Blanca played a two with the idea
that if Bishop captures Capablanca gets
a queen into the game but here
Rubinstein played rock to h6 and it was
in this position that josé raúl
capablanca
resigned the game yes you heard you
heard me correctly it was in this
position that also roll kappa blanka for
the first time in this 1911 tournament
of san sebastian his first big
international tournament in his life has
lost the game at two none other than the
great
Akiba Rubinstein which is not all that
surprising since Rubinstein really was a
monster why did Capablanca resign
well urine check you have to move the
king of course you're gonna go King a5
you don't want to allow the rook behind
your king but it doesn't help simply
push up the c4 and now the a6 Square is
covered by the Bishop rook to a6 check
again would pick up the pawn if you
decided the Queen so you could try
something like room b6 block but it
doesn't help
rook captures and now if you capture the
rook Bishop captures pawn and White has
all of these super fast and passed extra
pawns but if you grab a queen again the
a sexpot square is guarded rook checks
you have to move the King route captures
and now white is just again completely
winning so first loss for Jose ro
Capablanca here and Akiba Rubinstein
still without a loss in the 1911
tournament of San Sebastian will he
repeat his great success of the nineteen
in tournament in st. Petersburg we'll
just have to wait and see as we do have
two more games in this great tournament
before we go somewhere else in this
cover Blanca saga but definitely an you
know incredible player I also would like
to mention somewhere I believe in 2017 I
made a video on the Rubenstein's
immortal game back then my videos were
extremely short I believe it's like a
four-minute video for four and a half
minute video but it's his famous game of
rock lady versus Rubenstein from 1907
really an insane game and there I've
also mentioned a bit more about Akiba
room inch 9 so it will be the first
thing you see in the description below
feel free to check it out it's you know
extra four minutes but it's really an
amazing game so definitely
as you can see Rubenstein had excellent
tournament results he could defeat was a
rule capablanca and if not for the
outbreak of the world war one he would
definitely get his chance to challenge a
lots before the title and later when
Capablanca became world champion he
offered he offered Rubinstein terms to
challenge kappa blanka for the title if
he could you know gather enough sponsors
for the prize money but the Rubenstein
couldn't get to the sponsor for the
prize money so that match also never
happened and the Rubenstein got to live
a very long life he lived I believe up
until he was 80 years old and he kept
you know kept up with the chess world
for the rest of his life for example a
Wikipedia I found that his children
brought him games during the botanique
versus missile Chess Championship match
and that he was following the match so
an incredible player and one player that
definitely deserves his own saga I
really do hope will one day we start to
the Akiba Rubenstein saga as oh he's
really an amazing player and his games
are really insane because like
capablanca he was really a magician in
the middle game a virtuoso in the end
game but he also started opening a
theory so that was definitely to his
benefit but yeah first loss for
Capablanca Rubinstein still without loss
we'll see how the whole tournament
done wines and yeah that's the game I do
hope you enjoyed it and that you're
enjoying the Capablanca saga so far do
check out rod levy vs. Rubenstein the
first thing you'll see in the
description below I would like to thank
Brian Quran Enrico Pollini Jose Victor
Gonzalez goo Rock
Lester la force and Tyler Davis for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot I really appreciate it
as usual you can check - in my previous
videos here thank you all for watching
and I will see you soon hopefully with
some more interesting content and yeah I
have an excellent rest of your Monday